we all know gas prices continue to go up
along with food supply now many reaching
out to us telling us their pools
services those prices also increasing
and with the warmer weather many of
people are getting ready to enjoy their
pools but some say the increase is
starting to become a problem sally
jaramillo explains why those prices are
rising
we came in and there was a ton of calls
jeff kennedy owns alchemist poll service
he says now is when pool services
increase as people prep their pools but
owners are also noticing another change
one of the largest chlorine plants in
the us it was destroyed in a fire back
in uh august of 2020 i believe it was
hurricane laura that took it out that
particular place they produced 40
percent of the chlorine tablets kennedy
says in january his company raised
prices to an additional 20 dollars a
month it's expected many others could be
doing the same
i was paying about 110 a month before
now i'm paying 150 a month rob pistone
relies on a pool service once a week and
has seen the rise in prices compared to
last year i pull people and i go to the
pool supply stores to try to buy
supplies
and you can't get what you're normally
used to getting andy maiden maintains
his own pull he says he's seen the
increase at stores too purchasing
chlorine tablets and other types of
chemicals to make sure that the
chemicals are all in line i've seen a
slight increase at some of the supply
stores maiden says while his neighbors
are trying to adjust with these new
prices he recommends if you can do it
yourself do it sally jaramillo live
local now